[Music]
hello there welcome back to another
episode and hello from me Priyanka
today we'll introduce Google cloud
pub/sub a messaging service that allows
you to send and receive messages between
independent applications we'll also run
through a quick demo of the self-paced
lab where we will explore various
publishing and subscribing activities
and you want to know more how to test
this with your own application after the
lab we'll check out our free trial
credit to get started on Google cloud
platform let's first answer what pub/sub
means as a service ok so a
publish/subscribe service is a messaging
service where the sender's of messages
called publishers are decoupled from
receivers of messages called subscribers
the published messages are categorized
into topics subscribers who have
expressed interest in a topic will
either pull related messages or choose
to get push messages from the topic key
to the service is that neither party is
required to have any knowledge of the
other Club pops up is great for
distributing event notifications take an
example of a service that accepts user
signups it can send notifications
whenever a new user registers and
downstream services can subscribe to
receive notifications of that event
there are even examples closer to home
you know that smart home technology your
cell phone now yes I do love my Google
home well the pops-up service is a part
of the architecture that supports the
streaming of data from residential
sensors to the backend servers that are
hosted on cloud the ability of cloud
pub/sub to ingest millions of streaming
events per second from anywhere in the
world also allows you to respond to the
events as they happen
cloud pub/sub forms part of clouds
stream analytics solution which provides
a number of useful applications such as
performing sentiment analysis
identifying general patterns and trends
and data monitoring the performance and
reach of campaigns and crafting messages
in real time
time again for quick labs the cloud
pub/sub lab is available for use with
g-cloud command line tool as well as
through the Google cloud platform
console you can check out the link to
start quick labs here and for a limited
time you can try these labs for free
each of the labs cover the activities of
setting up a topic to hold data
subscribing to a topic to access the
data and then publishing and consuming
messages with a pol subscriber the lab
will take about 30 minutes to complete
so far in the lab we've created a pub
subtopic using the Google cloud platform
console and added a subscription you can
see the number of subscriptions listed
for the topic is 1 you can use the
console to publish a message to pub sub
topic in this case we are publishing the
message hello demo to view the message
you use the subscription to pull the
message from the topic well there we
have it we hope you enjoyed this episode
and would love to hear more about how
you use or would use Google cloud pops
up and don't forget you can apply what
you've learned today with a $300 free
trial credit to get started on Google
cloud platform you can also learn more
about cloud pub/sub through a number of
other Google cloud training resources
all the links are listed below
thanks for watching and see you soon
want to know more about deployment
manager check out last week's episode
where we dive into a lab and highlight
the service